hello look at the lobby games last
weekly chats or every tuesday at two
p.m. pacific right here on gamespot com
law fella porec solid did makara happy
st. Patrick's Day to all you viewers
watching live and on-demand on gamespot
com and in st. Patrick's Day tradition
we're going to kick it off with a
discussion about Japanese role-playing
games Justin hey wolves alexa ray
corriea hey there folks hey young good
yeah thanks for wearing green exactly
thanks fer no I never gone on going on I
forgot you forgot me I got my brooch I
feel like the Irish DNA is like a like a
get out like I can kind of get away with
it yeah a little bit I've got some green
underwear dr. Engel Oh TMI you've got a
bit of our CNN as well the right do I'm
out great I spent the past five days
past week playing role playing games oh
really so it passed my mind when I was
putting my wardrobe together you've been
playing and this morning you were
playing I wanted to get you on to talk
embarrass the actual game that came airs
not the demo that's packed with it but
you've just come off a stream for Final
Fantasy 15 so please tell me everything
about the demo for Final Fantasy 15 so I
know a lot of people people are
complaining about the dialogue or the
music just like them but I really like
it hmm um I really like that it opens
with I really like that it's about four
dudes who are clearly like really good
friends and it's not like four dudes
that have a mass to this group by
traveling around the world and picking
up random strangers right like I can
tell their friends when this guy this is
knocked a seasoned main character when
he is out of MP and can't attack any
more one of the guys will run over and
sort of put themselves in front of him
and shield him while he's like healing
cooling in the beginning cutscene as
they all get up and they pass him he's
still sleeping they all tap is like tap
his cheek like get up buddy and they're
like they're all on TV and I really like
it oh yeah I'll friends because they got
together at a korean like kpop festival
okay it's really weird for me and if you
go back and look at the footage that we
are that we just played today from our
now playing you walk into a gas station
and there's three dudes dress
Nathan Drake like in scarves and
t-shirts okay and then you have your
four guys who are all in like black
leather trench coats yeah does it's like
slipknot chic or something yeah it's
like super weird looks good like I don't
the character design looks great but it
doesn't fit with like four dudes going
camping Coleman tents got my lamp and
haha muscle I know whether having said
oh my lamp I can't say I got my lamp the
campaign got your lamp the camping is
actually the best part it's fine what's
the capping of the bed is it just save
games or what is it well when you when
you can't you that's when all of your
experience points for the in game day
aren't tallied up oh and then you level
up and the one guy ignis the guy with
the glasses depending on the animals
that you've killed that day yeah animals
they've killed depending on the thing
that you've done or the supplies that
you found he cooks and he'll make
different dishes and each dish gives you
different status booths like one gives
you only critical hits one makes you
immune to poison another one like like
bumps up your attack and defense rate
one like like like completely i think it
was like you have like a solid defense
and they're called like fresh sharp mu
and like a little cute little names but
it's depending on the food you eat and
that's really cool and if you don't hunt
and you keep camping without hunting you
eat toast oh nah that's pretty good and
i guess and there's no buff on that
stuff at all no you just have some toast
guys sitting around a campfire eat toast
so I one of the things like I'm not a
big final fantasy fan I'm playing final
fantasy 7 at the moment of my Vita and
we kind of like for the first time kind
of and I'm enjoying it but the
turn-based stuff is never really liked
your the action whooping stuff is never
really liked stroke accorded me what a
bit like the action the actual combat is
different this time right because it
seems just like a normal action game
when you see footage of it yeah so I'm
actually going I'm going to 15 in type 0
which I just reviewed review and I guess
today have the same director so the same
guy works on both of them and both of
them use a real-time combat types heroes
combat is very good I think 15 s is a
lot sharper although type series is
amazing um you're literally running
around a battle in free time and it's
it's it's an action game you get into a
get into a fight as you can see here
like you are in real-time reacting to
him there's no taking turns you can hit
you can
Terry in this game you can actually
throw your weapon across the battlefield
and teleport to it like strike an enemy
and then bring yourself right up to the
enemy which is cool they run yeah yeah I
think a lot of people are probably going
to be buying final fantasy type-0 in
order to play this yeah but it's time
zero worth it as well from what you
played yeah i mean i really liked it we
never originally a PSP game so this
version is redone it was never released
outside of Japan right no only Japan got
it and it did really well in Japan 2011
or something and the game I mean the HD
nesta really doesn't really extend to
the whole game like the main characters
are all beautifully rendered and it
looked great but then they talked to an
NPC in the NPC is like the flat PSP like
mouth moving like this person and it's
like all right like you didn't do
everyone I just and whatever that the
Grim Fandango kind of sober feel a bit
ago yeah but it's a the game's really
good the story is composing and
comprehensible so the store does do
these tie together at all or is this
like a the same kind of final fantasy
everything is its own complete
standalone game adventure everything is
its own complete standalone game
adventure although type 0 does use the
whole Lucy fal'cie crystal thing that
final fantasy 13 daily oh definitely
originally 13 type 0 and then 15 when it
was named vs 13 we're all part of the
same universe but then they sort of
broke them up and did their own thing
and I think 15 is looking better for it
and like every game Sid makes an
appearance what a little bit different
in this one yeah there's a CID um it's
the lady okay she's a mechanic all I've
seen her in the photo doctor yeah he's
new I have a lot of problem looks like a
botanic oh yeah she oh she look like
Emma comic look at this look at her
she's just like granted she's she's nice
like she's super cute and I love the way
she spell come on look what she's
wearing um hahaha I was gonna work on a
car yeah but not dressed like that but
look at that card that's a cool car you
remember the opening shot of
transformers two was it where Megan Fox
is on the draped over the like in the
like just oiling orb like polishing the
top of in your life for God's sake yeah
somebody watch that movie apparently
yeah I'm a little
I mean I like the idea that stood
because every find manatees it's so
ridiculous so bad it's not even like oh
we're just like this is preposterous
what subtle whatever yeah I go first
every final fantasy has a CID yeah and
this is the first time it's been a girl
okay I'm cool I'm I still much you're
like in the music I think that was a
little bit divisive when we heard it
here in the office wow that's the music
like so the music is done by yoko
shimomura she's a long time video game
composer most recently she's been
working on the kingdom hearts series and
it's sort of a like upbeat whatever um I
really like to I really like the music
in this game it's very it's very very
upbeat it's like it's like it's daunting
it's like I don't know it makes me think
of phenom hearts like you walk into a
battle and it's like Oh Disney battles
where you whack each other with the keys
yeah and that same sort of bouncy
playfulness is still evident in um
difficult you still get those you know
traditional themes that the doctor ah no
no no that I like it all over here a
freaking out on this is mo actually a 15
so the demo I was told that if you do
everything and you don't explore like we
took some time to explore today I Peter
did some exploring if you go look at
Peter's footage from tax he actually
tried to steal a car oh I'd like try to
leave walked up to the road and was
stopping cars and trying to get that
much is cool but it's about three hours
long go through everything in that demo
and there's like you track of 18 it and
we started doing that you go get money
to fix your car you can go to the
chocobo ranch hang out like there's a
lot to do and I was does this um start
saw it doesn't bode well do you think
for the full product is is it a good
taster considering you played pub 0 and
that seems like a pretty solid final
fantasy oh yeah no it's one of the
better Final Fantasy titles to come out
in recent years I liked it a lot better
than I liked 1313 was sort of the
hallway and granted tix arose missin
structure is like their rooms connected
to each other and then you can go do
side quests and stuff but it wasn't so
linear like you get to run around on the
overworld and explore and to side quests
and cats chocobos and breed chocobos you
can see Bree chocobo toes yeah and it is
a demo this carries over to the main
game whenever they all fell right duh I
don't know actually I don't want to say
because I don't think it does I believe
that I think that's what there is no
said game sorry but who knows
in the main games coming up yeah for
sure first being a good taster I think
so cool so is it fair to say that
between the sort of Western release of
type 0 and this demo for Final Fantasy
15 as a longtime fan of the franchise
are we now looking at a Renaissance
final fantasy well fans of the genre no
is it to go with that stupid cliched
phrase um are you siding Attack Position
I love types harrell I'm in cry
encourage everyone to go and buy and
play 60 the demo I mean so only way you
can get the demo you basically by the
demo and then you get a copy of type
Sarah with this is crackdown on halo 3
all over again pretty much but it's
great I there's a lot to look forward to
and that's exciting i like it i think i
think people should be a little less you
know start being skeptical i think
they're big got a lot today be happy
excellence and the review on gay com of
type 0 is going up when that's up
already it's about our video review is
on the way i gave it an eight cool again
it means it's great awesome flexray
curry i thank you so much for coming on
thank you all about final fantasy and
we're going to be back pretty soon with
some up that we're going to talk about
mario party but then Nintendo started
dropping crazy bombs about friggin
iphone games and platforms that were
will change the face of hardware
whatever god damn allah means we're
going to dive into that in just couple
of minutes the first of all as its st.
Patrick's Day we thought we'd show off a
bunch of trailers for some Irish video
games that are currently in development
later on today for 30 pacific time we're
going to be doing a big old stream we
have some irish beers and play some
irish games we're first of all here's a
little look at a game that's coming i
believe to xbox one in a couple of
platforms hopefully later this year this
is the little acre we'll be back in a
second
you
so to watch out and all those crazy
folks over at Nintendo done drop some
weird news today we were originally
going to talk about mario party today on
the show but there's a bunch of crazy
stuff came here today Randolph Ramsey
Justin hey Waldo blame to me first of
all before we get into the mobile game
stuff what is this new Nintendo platform
what if anything do we know about it we
know everything about really right now
don't ya we have it behind meet we can
talk about the course Nintendo came by
this morning yes 02 showed us yeah and
that what is called the code name is the
in X or Nintendo X stands for 10 and
they're gonna put a money sign at the
end of it total beam it in Tendo which
is disguise which all small we're just
lying obviously right now because all we
know in those two letters yes basically
what I think with what everyone else
knows right now yeah which is hey we're
doing something we've got a new piece of
hardware that we're working on and we're
not gonna talk about ill make sure you
please understand which I guess I'm
really news because I guess the
assumption for most people is ya gotta
be worth much something now in any and
they've said in interviews every company
has said as soon as we're done as soon
as this platform launches we begin work
on the next platform so it's basically
that this is saying they have a firmer
idea and they probably started more
hardcore into prototyping and yeah we'll
hear more in 2016 at least the code name
doesn't sound like a Wang yeah it's all
right yeah and they have kept code names
before avenue i'm trying to think was
the wii was revolution revolution and
I'm sorry when the coleman was project
dolphin nintendo 64 I think that Super
Nintendo they kept the code name of
Super Nintendo all right so they can
code name yeah right I've no idea what
was we use code name I can't remember
though that was the revolution yeah oh
sorry you guys don't worry we yeah I
don't think we knew I was coming out
they were like it was the pro kind of
like the week's episode ever look up we
thought it was the controller yeah and
still the rest of the consumers in the
world think that as well so I that's the
exciting news but it's also what we know
the least about yes because what they
were actually talking more
and definitely in a play to get
shareholders up is that they are going
to start developing games for mobile
devices they said in 20 watt is
specifically said in 2013 we're not
going to make games on smartphones
because and and we think that when you
look at the future of Nintendo later on
you will see that this was a good choice
and I 1 2015 yeah he's basically saying
we're gonna make games for smartphones
yeah because we need to make money so
are they going to make them themselves
or what's this parse partnership but
when I mean we've already heard that in
Nintendo has said specifically their
licensing out their IP when other
developers want to use Nintendo or ours
elbow Mario those characters they're
going to be able to we've already seen
that with puzzles and dragons with a
mario theme like that's not developed by
Nintendo internally that's developed by
the puzzles & Dragons team and we've
seen that previously we haven't seen
it's probably to the level that we're
gonna see it for a really long time like
back in the 80s when we add Mario games
put on the computer devices that nobody
played are those really terrible Zelda
games that on CD I yeah yeah
specifically for this though they
partnered with a Japanese mobile company
which are the biggest of like mobile
games development companies in and
called DNA and if you ever been to a
tokyo game show you will see you know
like one of the biggest boots they will
is always going to be a DNA booth and
it's always weird going there and seeing
all these like massive array of games
yeah you know we in the Western press
don't know anything about the only one I
know is rolando I think they worked on
mm no like most of that stuff is like
more casual right and is way I fuelly
targeted for the japanese market so i
guess you know the assumption that world
making here is that the nintendo and DNA
partnership is going to result in gangs
that are going to come out in the West
all right and I think some DNA stuff
most DNA stuff actually just stays
within the country right so it's still
bit of a question mark as to what will
actually hit western markets but well I
think the bigger thing that we're going
to see from this is not necessarily the
games they're coming out from it but but
that partnership in help it and helping
I think DNA is going to help nintendo
create an overall infrastructure that's
not judge i mean we've already seen we
get rid of club nintendo yeah what
they're going to do is have a cohesive
vision which they've needed for so long
which they play and catch up on and they
need a cohesive this isn't just our home
console and mobile games and 3ds games
like these me to all be brought together
and I
think that's something that DNA is going
to help them with that's a common online
infrastructure yeah that works across
yeah whatever consoles they have in the
future so it's just the one thing you
want ID throughout all event and you
know it's Nintendo you know finally I
guess catching up to you know having
those type of you know similar services
across the board yeah and you know I
think this is actually a pretty good
move for them like you mentioned got to
start notice the shareholder play and it
truly is because I think the stock went
up like $23 off really it would weigh
thirty percent in what was what
shareholders been asking for for a long
time and in that sense they needed to do
this too because you know they're a
publicly traded company I do have to
rehash the DF stuff seems to be doing
fantastically well as our bus and we're
going to see some I mean to put it
bluntly we're going to see some shitty
games out of this we've already seen
stuff like Pokemon shuffle that is on
3ds that is basically a match 3 game
yeah with microtransactions and we're
going to see more of that but I don't
think that's necessarily a bad thing if
that's the kind of thing that can keep
Nintendo afloat because of course like
why not chase after that that market
that's going to spend money on that and
if that gives you the money and the
freedom to keep making the games that we
love as long as it doesn't shut out that
that creativity in that freedom like
this could be a really good thing i've
seen some people freaking out about it
especially the combination i guess with
DNA because there's this term do you
know you've lived in Japan before
gashapon is that like a it's some sort
of like term for those those those like
bowls you get ahead of machines you kind
of put the money in and you get random
so like there was this thing that
happened a couple of years ago where a
digital or virtual gashapon became a
thing and DNA have been like done the
story forefront of that where you're
basically goading free-to-play games and
goading people to like just put in extra
money with the you know random almost
like a lottery system like it's getting
like random prizes so so ketchup on
basically it correct me if I'm wrong
it's where you you pay a certain amount
of money and you get a drop and you get
an item basically and what that is is
randomized right so yeah it does sort of
incentivize you I didn't get the right
thing I need to know to keep putting
money into it but I think I guess I
Crossy Road like that's kind of what
that's doing right and we have the same
thing with a lot of Diablo I mean we're
not necessarily paying real money into
to those hardcore experiences but you
get the same thing with
destiny with you know the drops that
you're getting from those any world of
warcraft played into that at the very
beginning where you're not paying for
you know of course individual items but
when you go on a raid you're hoping that
drop is the good little thing that you
really want and that's what keeps you go
against the key difference there's
you're not paying no so you you're just
playing it because but with world of
warcraft you're paying monthly you're
playing a flat fee and this is basically
saying well we can get more money from
people who want to spend a whole lot on
it and there are some people who maybe
we'll do this once a month I just worry
about things like for instance the
amoeba is where a Nintendo have like a
created this thing which is clearly like
a you know super fan you want to pay us
an extra money because the meebo is for
all like they do that don't actually do
that much like it in terms of their like
individual like a bit like the
technology isn't that so far ahead and
incredible it's more of a like a
collector's item look I'm all for this
because I'm I'm selfish right like I
want Nintendo to keep making games for
me yeah and i think you know less let's
be frank if they keep going away they're
going now they're not going to be able
to do that for you know for a long time
right so they need to expand their
market they need to get beyond the super
fans which i think we are where the
types that actually buy amiibo because
you know we grew up in nintendo we have
this built-in passion for the brand so
they need to like find new customers for
that and i always go back to my
experience with my kids right so I've
got two kids you know I would love them
to play Nintendo games the five-year-old
is still a little bit young all he does
is play ipad games because that's easy
right you just point and drag and do all
that stuff and there is one game there's
like camp pokemon yeah that is on iOS
he's playing right now but i would love
to us some you know Kirby or mario game
that he could get into and I can try and
you know instill that same passion I
have in him on a platform that is
already using I don't need to graduate
them to you know a 3 dias which is a lot
harder to use for kids alright and we
use so you know I think it's a great
move hopefully the crappy games will be
limited I mean Nintendo has yeah you
know hopefully some quality assurance
yes maybe they just do this now bring
back the seal of approval of the things
you don't done and dusted it's easy for
us to be armchair analytic ear CEO
because we want to like we feel like I'm
gonna make awesome decisions and
I don't have to worry about keeping all
these people were giving me money happy
yeah but I Nintendo has to balance a lot
of things and that the frightening thing
is when you think about oh how much
they've [ __ ] up online their online
infrastructure leading up to now has
been garbage tell me bo is like that is
not a good model for anything does that
give me a lot of hope that they'll be
able to do like I know I always have
hope for Nintendo because they made I
have that nostalgia they need so many
great things growing up they still
continue to make really fun experiences
they've made a lot of mistakes though so
I need you still have to approach with
caution yeah he could still completely
make this a terrible thing hopefully the
combination of them working with other
partners will you know steer them in the
right direction I guess we'll have to
wait and see I thank you so much fun d
for coming on talkies about this and
we're going to be back in a second is
talking about battlefield hardline our
boy in the battlefield Ryan Schubert's
going to come on ever first of all one
more trailer for an Irish video game
this is actually available on Steam
early access at the moment this is Frank
and John check it
bye
the latest in the battlefield series
battlefield hardline PvP you cops vs
robbers it's fine players it's finally
out today both single-player and
multiplayer component and our boy in the
battlefield mr. Ryan schubert is here to
tell us all about it sir you've been
playing a lot of multiplayer over the
weekend I've played a ton of multiplayer
weekend at tell me what you think about
this video game I think it's really fun
I think they've put out a just supremely
entertaining multiplayer game when you
stay entertaining what does that mean is
that it's not a kind of sounds like a
backhanded compliment a little hell fun
to watch but not to play it's it's not
as sort of seriously toned as the last
two maybe a little bit more
tongue-in-cheek the way bad company was
and it's I mean you can drive a couch
around no I mean it's not that's not too
serious and the you know they paint the
world with you know a lot of here a lot
of call outs like you wouldn't titanfall
can hear the people talking and at one
point last night after a few gunshots
went off i heard a cop say i am the law
you know I cracked up and it's like okay
you know the theme is actually fun it's
refreshing it feels less stiff and
battlefield 4 did the company has a lot
to answer for a lot to live up to after
the disaster that was battlefield 4 they
certainly do and I'm not sure that this
is going to necessarily win a lot of
fans back because does it feel like a
full game or is it to me it doesn't like
to me it feels like a mod but like a
really good mod you know like back when
we got desert combat in 1942 like where
it was something that felt like a lot of
work went into it a lot of energy went
into it but it doesn't feel like a
completely unique game
and it like frostbite maybe it's
frostbite but it's just not well
designed for the kind of game play like
you know for this sort of Grand Theft
Auto high-speed racing the game isn't
designed for like the collision yeah and
the handling and a lot of just really
wonky things happen when you drive
vehicles so it's kind of fun in spite of
some like technical limitations and
thematic stuff right then that's why
said like if you downloaded it as a mod
you would say oh this is just fun hmm
and I like this and it's refreshing and
to be completely fair like I'm more of
the camp that bad company 2 was the sort
of height of multiplayer in map design
yeah and I was not a very big fan of
conquest as a result I mean I've played
most of the games in the series but I
just never quite latched on to it which
is interesting cuz it's like the primary
modal right it is but in this in
duration I think they nailed it really
like I sat down at one point and played
through the entire playlist of maps in
conquest and I enjoyed absolutely every
one of them Wow and on top of that
there's a lot of new game modes that are
not all great but they're all varied
enough and different enough and fun
enough that if you sit down to play and
get tired of one you can switch to the
other and still enjoy yourself yeah
whereas I felt like in battlefield 4 I
could really like hit a wall playing one
game mode and realize that I didn't
really want to switch to another one
maybe the exception is that team
deathmatch in this game is kind of
broken yeah my way so they've gone to a
full 64 player a team deathmatch which
is just chaos into itself and then the
map sizes are all pretty small which is
appropriate for a team deathmatch but
then all the spawns are around the edge
right and I figured out at one point
that you can basically spawn and just
run around the edge in circles and
you'll just catch people spawning as you
go and it's not that fun and it's kind
of a deep way of racking up kills but
you know there you are I guess are you
enjoying it more than battlefield 4
multiplayer when I first came out um
yeah
I think so I mean for when it first came
out it was I was a lot more excited
about it and thematically i prefer the
like wars onra to the crime yeah but
this is probably more fun not maybe not
all the maps are best designed but it's
it's just it feels entertaining it feels
good let's talk about the thematic side
of it then is it interesting have it
like would you say 64 player like 30
cops vs 30 robbers just shooting the
[ __ ] out of each other in a steady it
conceptually it makes basically knows
that and I think that's the thing is
that's part of the having fun side of it
and driving a cash yeah driving a couch
but and conceptual II though it does
actually work within a few of the setups
like it's not all just completely random
like why would you do this you know the
new heist mode which is involved like
breaking a vault and getting the money
out there's a few maps that that is like
really purpose-built for and we haven't
had a good a good set of purpose-built
maps in a long time like battlefield 3
and 4 when 3 launch they made a big deal
about every game mode was on every s
which was old and big red flag that was
it it was kind of a bad idea yeah you
know there were just some math words
made no sense especially rush which has
more of a linear feel to it and like it
tells a story yeah and going in a circle
on the circular map doesn't tell a story
really and that's better here I wouldn't
say that you know they've gotten rid of
rush which is kind of disappointing and
rush was that storytelling multiplayer
mode and I don't think any of the new
ones quite hit that mark yeah outside of
counter-strike we really don't get a lot
of games that have hostages is such a
main focus either act right and yes
there's a hostage mode there's basically
two modes that are five versus five you
know sort of single elimination matches
in the sort of kind of like vein that I
guess yeah and I actually used to like
that the version of that mode when it
was in call of duty called Search and
Destroy yeah yeah and I just thought it
was a great break from the way
the rest of the game modes play it is
like totally different you know you only
had one life you know I used to play at
hardcore so you didn't have any many
maps or anything and you really had to
communicate with your team and they've
sort of a kind of added that to
battlefield 4 but it kind of fell flat
and now they've got two modes they've
got crosshair and rescue rescue the
hostage mode it's a little bit more the
flow of that one doesn't quite play as
well as I'd hoped it would but the
crosshair mode where one of the players
is the VIP yes who gets a golden gun and
nothing else and is being escorted
others a clip of a oh yeah that mode is
actually really fun it's like best of
nine and so there needs to be a
battlefield five this year or really
soon or is this kind of good and will
the state your desire for a battlefield
game right now I think for some people
it will for some people this is maybe
another an opportunity to try a
battlefield game without getting into
like a core battlefield game I mean my
thing is I think they should hold off as
long as they can on battlefield five I
think they need to regroup reconsider
what they're doing the frostbite they've
got battlefront on the way and on top of
that they're still sinking a lot of
support in the battlefield 4 like the
you know if anybody's noticed premium is
still full price Rio there's still like
milking that wow you know put that in
perspective that's like what 18 months
old yeah and you know by comparison
titanfall came out around this time last
year MN all the dlc is free now really
so you know if you look at just like the
business model they're both EA so you
can't really necessarily blame EA but
you know the community test environment
is still an active thing they're still
doing new map work with it there's a
community map project going on they've
been doing nighttime versions of sub map
so I think what they're doing is they're
supporting battlefield 4 to keep that
core audience entertained with
battlefield 4 and hardline is just
another nicer version version yeah so we
talked a lot about the multiplayer it
seems like it's pretty solid seems like
it's a return
to form a step in the right direction at
the very least and one of the single
player from the little I've seen through
and you guys did a stream and we had the
reviews gone up on gamespot today as
well it seems like you can either mow
down everyone or you've got this magic
badge you can just flash in front of
people know like I okay oh god that guy
named flash my magic badge Adam and how
much have you played and what do you
think of it it's kind of looks a lot
different to the multiplayer so I've
only played the first two episodes and
our union levels so right so it's
divided in two episodes and the episodes
are actually delivered in an episodic
fashion they have like a next time on
and previously on kind of structure or
seed roll yeah and I actually like that
a lot really I you know I'm as I've
gotten older for me to find time to like
really dig into a single player game
actually being able to treat it as an
episodic makes it kind of easier to
digest yeah it's actually kind of how I
played the last call of duty game 2 and
I think it's a good structure and you
know now that it's that you know EA is
doing it looks like it's really come
fully mainstream and the Telltale's been
doing it for plenty of time the auth you
almost wish that they did this like that
like that I do I really yeah I mean to
me especially because this is sort of a
slightly off brand battlefield I think
it would have been kind of cool if they
released the full multiplayer with like
two episodes of the single-player you
know bring the price point down a little
bit to get other people through the door
and then as they release the story we'd
have more time to decide whether we want
to follow the story or you know just
stick to the multi player so when you're
playing the game are you mostly shoot
everybody or you a flash badge get be
down the graph so again i only got into
the first to sort of levels which are
still kind of tutorial and i have to
admit that as we were doing it on the
livestream last week i was a little bit
sort of disappointed at how slow it was
i I just I just wasn't ready for battle
field to be giving me like a stealth
game yeah like I wasn't ready translator
in the reviews on yeah I mean it was
it's sort of out of left field and you
know maybe that's because I'm not that
familiar with visceral but like yeah you
just saw the clip on the screen like you
you know you tossed shell casings to
distract guards and then you you know
run up flash your badge and you know
Miguel pointed it out in his review how
like there he said exactly said they're
like vampires like to the Holy Cross
yeah thank you flash the badge and they
like immediately what they're like
without these heavily armed guys with
like vests and guns are like oh man guys
got a badge better okay okay you know
and then if you slightly botch that they
go full lethal right away and there's
nothing crazy about it it's like the the
eventual like evolution of this whole
single-player multiplayer campaign being
different is that you get multiplayer in
a single pair pack campaign it could be
completely different games it looks like
and honestly I kind of feel like you
know at some point we should consider
even like considering them different
games like reviewing them separately
yeah you know cuz I don't think it's
fair in them separately even selling
them separately I don't know if it's
fair to a game to like mark it down for
having a you know subpar one or the
other when you know you know that one
thing is primary for you is a layer I
don't remember because it's been a while
but I feel like probably you know
something like Bioshock which tried to
tack on and by Shaq to try to jack on a
multiplayer and I imagine it got a
little bit penalized for it it's like
well anyone resources in time and money
went into something which people wanted
that single player experience so it's
like maybe feeling if you put that money
towards heightening that that single
player experience would it have been
better it's interesting know when you
consider that so many single player and
multiplayer like components are actually
made by separate teams right surely this
one well and they real different too
yeah I mean that was the other thing
that was so jarring to me playing a
single player of this which was that you
know the controls are slightly different
there's different equipment that isn't
in the multiplayer game and I know
that's kind of common but it feels
really awkward to you you know the stark
contrast between a almost splinter cell
like or metal gear style experience and
the just wall-to-wall insanity the multi
player is there's not even a you know
they're not even similar yeah what is
the chance that it
some point in multiplayer don't be badge
mode where you just run up get badge
more like a new place collateral damage
mode in single-player where suddenly
you're just like forget mode imagine in
the current climate this will probably
wanted to stay away from that one yeah
just as far away as possible yeah so do
you think you're going to be playing
battlefield this is the sort like the
final question for like Battlefield fans
is that like you and iron and a bunch of
folks in the office I've been playing
three forever and they're playing for
forever do you think you're going to be
playing hard line like six months from
now that's a tough question I mean I'm
still kind of shell-shocked from
battlefield 4 yeah I kind of have almost
like a you know Captain Kirk to not
forgive them for the death of my son
feeling like I just I was so
disappointed at that roll out how it
took so long to fix it I don't like
premium I think that there's something
basically wrong with that model I mean
at this point for hardline I think I've
played I played the beta on ps4 and xbox
one I played the early access on xbox
one I've played on ps4 for the full
release none of that progress carries
over yeah if you plan all of those
platforms premium doesn't carry over
between platforms and there are people
who play on multiple platforms
especially the really hardcore fans and
they're expected to shell out a hundred
and ten dollars per flat for their for
the experience and that might not even
stink so much if you didn't have to redo
everything yeah from the ground up i
mean i've started hardline multi player
four times now you know and it's like it
just knowing that the process of yeah
who would that be like if it you had
your one account like it's all tied in
the battle log if you login your PPC and
like here's my character i bought on the
pc game switch over to ps4 and here's my
character and i don't have to redo any
of that's what I'm saying even if I even
if I could reason paying 110 dollars per
platform at least give me the time yep
the investment of my time of my life
it's not it's not too much to ask a
bottle log perhaps it might be at Ryan
thank you so much coming on tell us a
little
hardline very much appreciated and that
is a show for the week but we have one
final giveaway to get done I want to
thank Sony for sponsoring the lobby
throughout the month that has been March
and well husband and Beyond and before
that somebody sneezing in the packer
what's going on back there is that a
bola we won't arsenal one did mean is it
over shut up Eric does the money might
have found screaming from sales then we
don't know we're gonna have to cook I'll
figure that out in like three minutes
time what I want to say now he's got a
bunch of codes to give away from our
friends and Sony we have ten fifty
dollar vouchers for the PlayStation I
God look at that it's like magic for a
PlayStation Network all you do is tweet
at gamespot with the hashtag Sen sweeps
for your chance to win please do that on
the twitters and you can win one of
those ten fifty dollar gift cards to buy
whatever you want on a PlayStation
Network you buy transistor you could buy
what transistor was free recently
hotline Miami haha me too there we go I
really thought I was a good video game
some persona for you could what else did
you buy not a good solid ground zeroes
Metal Gear Solid original you could
there's all the PSone classics
Helldivers was reason held are just like
that is only good i I'm very guys I
wanted yeah very kiss that's pretty good
yeah yeah what's a desk so you can buy
down only but like no that was a success
other obviously better mary says I'm
deflecting that one all the testing
found boys graph to marry kids and sweet
AB gamespot hashtag sem sweeps and to
get in for a chance to be one of those
10 codes and again thank you very much
to stony for sponsoring the lobby and
thank you for watching the lobby and
thank you everyone's been tweeting in
happy st. Patrick's Day to everyone here
at gamespot we're gonna have a special
stream just for st. Patrick's Day we're
gonna have Irish beers and Irish games a
bunch of games you've heard of a bunch
of games you've probably not heard of
and a bunch of weird irish sports games
that came out on the playstation 2 and
we're going to try and play as well
that's going to be a 4 30 pacific time
that's just over two hours sorry just
under two hours from where we on there
so if you want to tune in to gamespot
com or twitch.tv for size games but then
we would love to see you thank you so
much just inhaled
chat with me on the cash today and that
wonderful said Patrick's Day shirt
really appreciated pitbull just like
mama used to play all right let's finish
oh thanks everyone the back for a
producing show as ever and we'll see you
guys in a couple of hours adios
you